[Music]
my fries I'm Batman
before he was a married man and Daft
twins George Clooney was Batman in the
franchise's third sequel Batman and
Robin the film turns 20 this year and
featured uma Thurman as poison ivy and
Arnold Schwarzenegger as mr. freeze
stay cool
boy I thought it was truly like a comic
book coming alive it was so unique in
its style and everything in the
performances were great and for the
first time on film fat girl chicks like
you give women a bad name I don't know
it again I think I think if I did it
right now I'd be much better bad girl I
just like didn't want to be in the suit
it was so uncomfortable maybe tone down
the baby the nipples and and and I get I
do much better job suit me up uncle
Alfred I made this like plaster body
mold of me and my entire face and every
inch of my body and just watching the
process of them build this costume and
all the sudden showing up in a set one
day when it was finished you're like oh
my god I can't believe I'm I'm gonna put
that on and be a superhero Chris
O'Donnell who returned to play Robin for
the movie told us he got to live out a
childhood fantasy my group is a kid ice
you know I had all the Batman and Robin
toys I watched the TV show it was it was
quite a thrill I got to drive the
Batmobile for Christ's sakes
come on chicks dig the car this is what
Superman works alone
[Music]
you